Hello Freak bitches.
When did this start?
When did the trigger warnings?
When did the safe spaces,
when did all this emerge?
Well,
it has its roots in the student radical
Islam of the 19 sixties,
especially the far left radicalism.
It really popped up in the 19 nineties
and the early nineties when I was
teaching in the US at that point and
which are,
you know,
I taught at Harvard from 93 to 98 and
there was a fair push for political
correctness especially in the early part
of the nineties,
but,
but it got pushed back down and
disappeared and went under ground.
It went underground is more accurate and
then it's just come back with a
vengeance in the last five years and I
think it's partly because we have all
these radical left political activist
departments at the universities,
women's studies being at the top of the,
of the list that have done nothing for
the last 30 years to even longer than
that.
Now it's almost 40 years,
30 years,
let's say,
have done nothing but produce an never
ending stream of ideological.
He reminded counter civilization,
political activists,
and that's all subsidized by,
by tuition and by the public purse,
and that's another thing we really got
to ask ourselves is why the hell are we
subsidizing revolution?
Why are we doing that?
It's crazy and it's dangerous.
It's dangerous.
What?
So what exactly is going on with women's
studies that you believe is fostering
revolution?
Wow.
You'd go on their websites and read,
read what they say.
I mean,
first of all,
for the,
for the women's studies types,
and this is a,
what would you call it,
a false anthropology.
There's this idea that way back when
there was a feminist paradise and that
would be like noble savage mode of
living where everything was
egalitarianism and a women dominated.
It was a matriarchal culture that was
put forward by Ucla anthropologist named
[inaudible] tests.
I can never pronounce her name properly,
but I think I got it.
And then that was overthrown by
patriarchal institutions,
start essentially starting at about the
time,
say,
of the,
of,
of Judaism.
And that was all overthrown.
And ever since then we've lived in an
oppressive patriarchy.
And that's what our culture is.
It's an oppressive patriarchy.
So they're pointing to one unsuccessful
society that they believe existed or did
it?
No,
no,
it didn't exist.
There's no evidence for whatsoever.
It's,
it's,
it's complicated,
but it's the,
it's the telling of a kind of
psychological myth as if it was history
and,
and anyway.
So,
so the basic claim is that Western
civilization is a brutish patriarchy and
that whatever positive things that might
have managed to accomplish were all
accomplished as a consequence of
oppression and,
and uh,
and theft.
And that the appropriate thing to do is
to restructure it from the bottom up.
And they mean that they mean that they
mean every single bloody concept.
And you can marry that modern
postmodernism and throw in a nice stash
of Marxism and you have the,
the ideological and motivated grounds
for social revolution.
And I'm just go online and look at a
dozen women's studies websites.
Just read them.
You can see what they say.
They produce political activists and
their goal is to restructure the
patriarchy.
Well,
what's the patriarchy?
While the patriarchy is Western
civilization and what is restructure
mean?
That's easy.
It means tear it down and destroy it.
Why?
Because it's a brutish system that's
predicated on nothing but oppression.
It's nothing but a tyranny in the,
in the eyes of the,
of the radical women's studies types,
heterosexuality.
That's a tyranny.
Capitalism.
Democracy.
Well,
that doesn't even exist.
And even if it did,
it would be a tyranny.
Everything's a tyranny.
And so you can ask these and and what
would they replace it with?
They replace it with their own
ideological utopia.
While we've already had 100 years of
that,
we saw what happened.
Oh well that doesn't matter.
That wasn't real Marxism.
That's what the bloody marks is.
Always say that wasn't real Marxism.
It's like,
oh,
how many millions of people have to die
before you're convinced that it's real
Marxism.
And I know what they mean by that too.
They mean,
hey,
if I was the Marxist dictator,
things would gone a lot better.
It's like a.
You should think again,
sunshine.
If you were the Marxists dictator,
things wouldn't have gotten a lot
better.
So if you're the sort of person that
thinks that if you would have been
controlled,
things would've gotten a lot better than
you're exactly the sort of person who
should never be in control.
So.
And it's resentment.
It's horrible.
Resentment,
you know?
That's an important point because I
think this is something that you've said
that I absolutely agree with that I
think a lot of this thinking and the way
people are behaving,
it seems based on revenge.
It seems based on revenge for awkward
upbringings,
so social uncomfortable of
uncomfortability.
That seems like there's something about
the way they view the world where they
want to get back at people that have
literally done them no wrong.
It's resentment for the burden of being.
It's deeper,
it's deeper,
but I mean human being human existence
is characterized by a fair bit of
suffering.
You know,
we're limited creatures and life is very
hard.
Everyone dies.
Everyone you love is going to die.
Most of the things you do,
all of the things you do will eventually
fail.
You know,
suffering is a certainty and it's very
easy for people to become resentful
about,
about being,
about existence.
You know,
these kids who shoot up high schools
and,
and these mass shooters there,
they're the perfect examples of,
of people who run on nothing but
resentment.
They're out to kill the innocent because
that's the best marker of a.
that's the best way of showing just how
much contempt they have for existence
itself.
Why punish the guilty?
They deserve to be punished.
It's a lot more malevolent and,
and,
and vengeful to punish the innocent.
It's like people are motivated to a
great degree by resentment of being.
And a huge chunk of that is manifested
in,
out to the dark side of the ideological
possession.
So I get to decide who my enemies are
and then I get to go after them and I
can go after them for every single thing
that's ever been done to me that isn't
good.
And well,
a lot of that's just built into the
structure of existence.
Then they group up,
they exhibit confirmation bias.
They all form some sort of a group think
and then they act accordingly and this
is what you've been warning against and
this is where I completely agree with
you in this way.
I think the subject is so important and
I love the way you've outlined all the
steps and the problems with Marxism and
ideologies in general that we are
dealing with this.
These are the beginning steps of it and
people who look at it now and they say
it's social change and social justice.
It's not.
That's right.
This is not going to improve things.
Implementing these policies will make
things worse.
They've made things worse.
Every single place they've ever been
implemented and often they've made
things so much worse that you actually
can't imagine it and people don't do the
reading.
I've done the reading,
I've done the reading.
I know how bad things can get.
They can get so bad that no matter how
bad you think they are,
you're not even in the bloody ballpark.
Well,
it's just so strange that these sort of
courses and these sorts of ideologies
are thriving in universities and it's
really disconcerting to someone who has
children.
You know,
that your children are going to go there
and they going to trade schools.
You know,
I think,
I think that,
wow,
I think I used to teach at Harvard,
just send them to trade schools,
the universities.
I think the universities,
I think you can make good,
reasonable case that the universities do
more harm than good.
Now,
I hate to say that.